you and i first bonded over you
explaining mung diving to me yes and i'm
still riding that thing hard okay so is
that do you think that's been done it's
a it's a cousin of the cleveland steamer
the dolphin no i don't think it has any
relatives and um
i think it's just its own
it has its own um
it's kind of like um
i don't know it's a mythology on all its
own i don't think it has any sexual
cousins or anything i think it's like
it's kind of like free soloing
yeah yeah yeah it's more like rock
climbing skydiving things like that like
extreme sports but you only have like a
two-day window to execute your hobby
well oh i mean you the window i think
the window is the the real wild card
there sure
you don't know how the corpse was
embalmed sure if it was if it was at all
if it's i mean you don't know if it's um
there's been a toxicology report if i
may recap that yeah or would you like to
please so um diving it's i love the
urban dictionary's definition which is
like um
when uh
when you and a friend go out to a
graveyard and you dig up a corpse that's
been um
but i think buried for like two days so
you know it's getting juicy
that's the key that's the key it's like
the the the
the uh
it's become bloated and yeah that's when
you know like the two or three day
window is the ju you know the level of
juiciness that you want to get and you
so it's like a team effort you have to
dig up the body um and then affix your
mouth to one of the orifices dealer's
choice and then your friend
stands on a tombstone jumps up onto the
the gut and all that fucking nasty dead
juice flies into your mouth and you got
highest and you get high
because what is the would it what are
you inhaling the embalmed juice or it
does that's the 65 000 question does
blood start to turn into like an
ammonia type thing well i think most
i think most embalming practices do um
they
they just they replace the blood in the
circulatory system with some kind of
something else like um yeah palm olive
or whatever and then you know
and so i think uh but the i don't even
know if they still use formaldehyde
yeah
but uh they need to start using whatever
they're using for lennon's corpse in red
square because that bitch is looking
fierce fresh and fabulous on display
dead as hell and okay so
who is lennon vladimir lenin was the guy
who was quite you know the start of the
uh the russian revolution the bolshevik
regime you have russian ancestry no
at all no
does not have any russian ancestry well
no with those cheekbones and that's wow
with those cheekbones and that mouth
well the the mouth was from l'oreal
[Laughter]
what is your ancestry
why
um like the the the uh uh genealogy or
the what do you call that 23andme
it is
uh irish scottish swedish and german
really
that's interesting i thought i just
thought yes because i thought you had
some russians ancestry and i was very
excited to talk to you about how every
russian i know has taught that lived in
russia grew up in russia or has uh
friends in russia
all fully believe not ironically not
bombastically that there are three other
people that have gotten plastic surgery
to look exactly like vladimir putin and
they all alternate oh mama let me tell
you something that so you want to talk
about the truth in russia mm-hmm no such
thing there isn't they've had fake news
for the idea that news could ever be
true is why they invented fake news but
imagine getting plastic surgery to look
like someone else i mean i'm just so
curious how they choose them how the
casting went down
kidding me they well first of all people
have no choice correct he's an autocrat
wait we're trying to texas we're not
talking about russia okay sorry
i'm so sorry
they're in i've talked to um expats sort
of a generation i guess they're like my
parents age so they were like um
there are 60s now here living in west
hollywood for like probably 30 40 years
yes and um they're like russians run
west hollywood thank god yeah they do
and they're you know they like every a
lot of immigrant communities they kind
of settle and then they all um in one
area and it's fierce and um
uh but they're like there's like they've
always known two truths like the truth
and then the real truth right and then i
think that there's just layers and
layers of it now that you don't even
it's it's just like
oh god it's just like this really
exhausting level of skepticism that is i
think hard on the soul
let me ask you about um what's going on
currently as i'm thinking about all that
uh with fentanyl
oh right go ahead somebody asked me for
fentanyl the other day on the street in
london just based on your vibe i guess
so i was well i was nodding off naked in
the sidewalk no but i was outside
smoking a cigarette like he asked me for
a cigarette and then he paused he was
like
you know i was like what he's like never
mind
[Music]
[Applause]